Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich hab überlegt wir könnten uns ja mal einen Trikotsponsor zulegen.
Also erstens haben wir schon einen und zweitens hört man die Zahlen eh nicht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 460 vom 15.
Mai 2023 und Linus ist wieder da. Hallo Linus. Hallo Tim. Ja,
ich bin ein bisschen fremd gegangen mit der Domas. Schön war's.
Weißt du, wer die Champions League gewinnt?
Na?
Mailand oder Madrid?
Haha, Hauptsache Italien sozusagen.
Wer weiß, Italien weiß ich nicht, aber Mailand nochmal drüber.
Und Mailand ohne Trikotsponsor. Ich musste ein wenig grinsen.
Das ist ja, also wer das nicht mitbekommen hat, Inter Mailand.
Und Trikotsponsor ist ja im Fußball nicht irgendwas, sondern das ist ja dann
wirklich in der Regel auch der Hauptsponsor.
Also da kommt so richtig die dicke Kohle und in den letzten ein,
zwei Jahren ist dann im Fußballgeschäft bei denen, die so richtig gierig sind,
die haben sich gedacht, oh geil hier, Krypto, Krypto, und da haben sich dann
irgendwie so Buden eingetreten, die kein Schwanz kennt.
Also deswegen wollten sie ja auch auf die Trikots, die richtig viel Geld geboten
und jetzt brechen die alle weg.
Also Hilda Meiland musste jetzt eben ohne Sponsorwerbung oder ist ohne Sponsorbedruckung
in seinen Spielen aufgelaufen,
weil die halt einfach nicht zahlen und zwar nicht nur nicht mehr zahlen,
sondern wohl auch teilweise noch nie bezahlt haben.
Also noch nicht mal die erste Rate auf die Kette gekriegt haben und das ist
nicht die einzige Geschichte.
Ja, die hat also ein Unternehmen mit dem Namen Digital Bits vorne drauf stehen.
Das ist eine Kryptowährung und die hatte im November 21 ihren Höchststand und
da sind die dann vom Ärmelsponsor zum Hauptsponsor geworden oder sowas.
Inzwischen ist aber der Wert der Kryptowährung auf Bruchteile eines US-Dollars
zurückgegangen, also auf 0,1 Prozent des Höchstwerts und ja die haben dann nicht bezahlt.
Und dummerweise geht's Intermailand auch nicht so gut, die machen auch dreistellige
Millionenbeträge Verlust, naja und genau Rom fiel auf den gleichen rein.
In Italien ist richtig krass aber es gibt es auch teilweise in Deutschland,
hier so Leverkusen und so die sind halt auch mit so Kryptovögeln am Ärmel aufgetreten.
Solange die zahlen ist das ja wenigstens noch nicht ganz so traurig aber das ist lustig.
Es gab da auch diverse Zahlungsausfälle und Sinneswandel,
also viele von diesen Unternehmen existieren teilweise nicht mehr in Großbritannien ähnlich,
also das war so richtig schlimm und das wird jetzt alles verschwinden zumal
diese ganze Kryptonummer ja gerade ganz wild abstürzt und im Hinblick auf neue
Regulierungen die hier eintreffen wird das sicherlich auch noch eine Weile so bleiben.
Es stimmt übrigens nicht unbedingt, dass das gerade so einbricht.
Also wenn du irgendwie Anfang des Jahres oder Ende letzten Jahres investiert
hast, hast du inzwischen wieder 70 Prozent Gewinn.
Ja es gibt natürlich immer noch, ich bitte dich du alter Krypto Bro,
nein nein nein, das ist doch voll gut, los kaufen kaufen kaufen, ich hab noch Bitcoin.
Ja ja, deine Tricks, deine Tricks.
Da kommen noch ein paar Dips, die ich dir verkaufen kann.
Hört nicht auf Linus, alles Quatsch. Ne ne ich meine das Problem ist hier geht
langsam das Personal aus, weil die alle jetzt vor Gericht gestellt werden für ihres Giebts.
Und die eine, ich meine auch die ganzen Banken, die jetzt sozusagen unter anderem
auch deswegen wegbrechen,
die auch gar keinen Bock mehr haben irgendwelche Kryptobuden zu finanzieren,
also auf einmal, Ja und das finde ich sowieso so interessant,
dass diese ganzen Kryptobuden vor allem deshalb jetzt ein Problem haben,
weil die ganzen Standardbanken irgendwie nicht mehr mit ihnen wollen.
Ja von wegen man braucht die nicht und so weiter und ja wir sind vollkommen
unabhängig vom Bankensystem und total die Weissagung für die Zukunft und das
neue System und so alles Unfug.
Ihr wollt einfach nur unsere Kohle haben und das wars und habt euch da was ausgedacht,
das ist einfach wirklich schäbig.
Insofern schön zu sehen, dass das jetzt so langsam stirbt und wer denkt,
das hat in irgendeiner Form eine Zukunft, hat das die ganze Zeit nicht so richtig verstanden.
So, wir haben Laptop-Taschen gesucht,
aber natürlich nicht, dass uns jemand sagt,
dass es sich bei den Laptop-Taschen um eine Laptop-Tasche handelt,
sondern wir haben ja nach der schnellsten und kreativsten Antwort gesucht und
dann gab es eine ganze Reihe und es war eine schwere Wahl,
aber Wir haben zwei solche Tasche zu vergeben und Urs hat uns direkt eine komplette Norm geschrieben.
Ich werde jetzt anfangen die vorzulesen, aber die ist mir zu lang und ich bin,
ich habe auch den Verdacht, dass Urs sich da eventuell bei Chat-GPT bedient haben könnte.
Das ist die Norm Nummer LNP458-2904.2023.
Norm für Klapprechnerfutural, die aus einem raumbildenden Packmittel aus Baumwolle
mit Druckeinhornstandate hergestellt wird und zum Transport für tragbare Computer
mit Klappmechanismus geeignet sind.
Erstens Anwendungsbereich, diese Norm gilt für raumbildende Packmittel aus Baumwolle,
die zur Herstellung eines Klapprechnerfuturals verwendet werden und mit einem
Einhornstandatemotiv bedruckt sind.
Das Packmittel muss aus 100% Baumwolle
bestehen und den Anforderungen des Ökotextstandards 100 entsprechen.
Da hat jemand gelesen, woraus das besteht. Abmessung.
Das Klapprechner-Futtereil muss passgenau für den vorgesehenen Klapprechner sein.
Die maximale Abweichung der Abmessung darf 2% betragen. Viertens Motivdruck.
Das Einhorn-Standarte-Motiv muss mittels Siebdruckverfahren auf das Packmittel
aufgetragen werden. Der Druck darf keine schädlichen Substanzen enthalten und
muss farbecht sein. Die Farbabweichung darf nicht mehr als 0,5% betragen.
Kurze Anmerkung Urs, damit entspricht dieses Produkt nicht mehr deiner Norm,
denn es ist kein Siebdruck, es ist ein Digitaldruck. Aber ok.
Ich meine, Normen sind auch dafür da, dass man sie bricht.
Stimmt, Revolutionäre! Vereinigt euch!
Tragfähigkeit. Die Tragfähigkeit des Futterals muss ausreichend sein,
um den Laptop sicher zu tragen.
Es darf eine maximale Belastung von 10 kg nicht überschritten werden.
Pflegehinweise. Das Packmittel muss pflegeleicht sein und darf bei einer Temperatur
von bis zu 40 Grad gewaschen werden. Wir empfehlen dem Klimazuliebe kalt waschen
und auf der Leine trocknen.
Vor dem Waschen auf links drehen, schon Farben und Druck stikmotiv.
Der Druck muss beim Waschen und Bügeln beständig sein. Siebtens,
Kennzeichnung. Jedes Packmittel muss mit einer dauerhaften Kennzeichnung versehen
sein. Die folgende Information enthält, erstens Herstellername und Zeichen,
zweitens Materialzusammensetzung, drittens maximale Belastbarkeit, Waschanleitung.
8. Konformitätsbewertung. Die Konformitätsbewertung des Parkmills muss durch
den Hersteller oder Importeur vor dem Inverkehr bringen geprüft und bestätigt werden.
9. Referenzen. Diese Normen… Willst du jetzt noch eine vorlesen?
Ja gut, ich… Es kommt noch eine.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu hart. Die restlichen Normenbestimmungen lest ihr
euch durch. Die Frage, ob das jetzt von ChatsGPT produziert wurde, dieser Text oder nicht.
Ich würde sagen, erstens, mein Tipp ist nein.
Zweitens, wenn doch, dann ist es gut geprimed.
Diese Norm ist teilweise mit künstlicher Intelligenz erstellt und auch ohne Unterschrift gültig.
Vor einer Inverkehrbringung ist allerdings abzuraten, da das raumbildende Packmittel
keine eingenähte Waschanleitung gemäß Norm LMP usw. besitzt. Ja, hat er recht.
Das ist der erste Platz, der geht an Urs,
du kriegst ein E-Mail von uns, oder falls du keine korrekte E-Mail-Adresse angegeben hast,
melde dich bitte nochmal bei uns und Annett hat sehr viel einfacher gelöst und
so den zweiten Platz gemacht, oder den anderen ersten Platz,
gibt ja nur erste Plätze. Ich möchte lösen.
Bei den Laptop-Höhlen handelt es sich natürlich um raumbildende Hackmittel.
Ganz einfach, Urs, du hättest ja gar nicht so viel Mühe machen müssen. Anett und Urs kriegen,
raumbildende Hackmittel nach LNP 458-2904, Doppelpunkt 2023.
Der Standard, der Hacker glücklich macht.
Ja, ist doch wunderbar. Also, schön. Ja, Tim meinte auch, ich war unklar darüber,
ob ich schnelle oder kreative oder richtige Antworten haben möchte.
Und die Antwort ist natürlich Ja.
Du hast das offen gesehen.
Womit wir beim Feedback sind.
Digitale Gewalt ist das.
Genau, wir hatten über den Gesetzesvorschlag zur digitalen Gewalt gesprochen
und festgestellt, dass er mit digitaler Gewalt nichts zu tun hat, was uns überraschte.
Ob des Namens des Gesetzesvorschlages.
Jura Alexander schrieb uns dazu, lieber Linus, lieber Tim, das Problem mit der
digitalen Gewalt ist kein juristisches Problem, denn die Fragen,
die ihr aufgeworfen habt, sind eigentlich alle gelöst. Aus meiner Perspektive
geht eure Überlegung in die falsche Richtung.
Die Suppe im Restaurant war versalzen.
Selbst wenn mich wegen diesem Kommentar jemand ausfindig macht,
dann kann er mich gerne auf Schadensersatz verklagen.
§ 823 BGB ist immer wegen Artikel 5 Grundgesetz mit der Meinungsfreiheit in
Verbindung zu sehen bei solchen Kommentaren im Internet.
Solange es sich um sachliche Kritik oder eine Meinung handelt,
werden die Schadensersatzklagen abgewiesen werden. Ein wenig Vertrauen in die
Rechtsstaat sollten wir dabei haben. Wenn jemand schreibt, der Koch ist ein
Hurensohn, dann Schadensersatz zu verlangen ist richtig.
Kann doch sein.
Und ebenfalls im Einklang mit den derzeitigen Gesetzen. Kann sein und ich sage
auch noch dazu und wenn schon.
Also was ändert sich mit diesem Gesetz? Man ist überhaupt in der Lage jemanden
zu verklagen. Ich arbeite als Anwalt für Arbeitgeber, die auf Jobportalen auf
das Übelste beleidigt werden. Das kann man leider nicht tun.
Weißt du was dir bestimmt beleidigt werden? Hurensohn. Alexander hat bei uns
kommentiert, der Koch ist ein Uhrensohn. Will ich nur mal so sagen.
Das steht in seinem Kommentar drin.
Das kann man leider nicht dulden. Unabhängig von der Frage, wie die Arbeitsbedingungen
waren, ist eine Beleidigung nicht das richtige Mittel, um Arbeitsbedingungen zu verbessern.
Das wäre mit dem Gesetz anders. Eigentlich endet nur die Anonymität auf solchen
Portalen. Ob dies gut oder schlecht ist, weiß ich leider auch nicht.
Ja, wir aber.
Das, aber da muss ich ganz kurz kommentieren. Also,
es mag ja sein, dass man jetzt hier in den Rechtsstaat vertrauen könnte,
aber wenn wir, gerade wenn wir von digitaler Gewalt sprechen,
ist es ja ein Problem, wenn auch bei nicht aussichtsreichen Ersuchen,
wer jetzt welchen Kommentar gemacht hat,
das katastrophale Konsequenzen haben kann für allerlei Menschen,
die tatsächlich digitaler Gewalt ausgesetzt sind.
Also, es gibt eine ganze Reihe Menschen, die sehr gerne nicht ihre Adresse im Internet haben wollen.
Und wenn die jetzt irgendwie bei jeder Äußerung von irgendjemandem,
der dann sagt, ach hier, da will ich übrigens nach BGB gegen vorgehen,
dann ist ja hier, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, nicht der Anspruch aus
Auskunft an diese daran gebunden, sondern allein das Vorgehen.
Das heißt, der Fehler, der dann passieren wird, ist, dass halt an die Adresse
von den Leuten gekommen werden kann. Und das ist ja dann schlecht.
Ja, also das, sagen wir mal, du äußerst dich so, dass es bestimmten gewaltbereiten
Bevölkerungsgruppen nicht gefällt und die wollen dann wissen, wo du wohnst.
Und dann stehen die vor deiner Tür, dann hast du vielleicht der digitalen Gewalt
ein Ende geschaffen und sie durch physische Gewalt ersetzt.
Also das scheint mir nicht zu Ende gedacht, in der Form.
Ja, dieses spezifische Problem der Adressveröffentlichung im Rahmen solcher Rechtsstreite,
Es muss vielleicht nochmal separat adressiert werden oder ist vielleicht auch
separat adressiert, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, wie das im Rechtswesen
jetzt gemeinhin so gehandhabt wird, aber das ist ja immer wieder so ein Problem,
von dem zumindest berichtet wurde.
Auf jeden Fall, das ist eines der Hauptgründe, warum Leute andere ungerne anzeigen.
Weil sie dadurch mindestens die Gegenseite durch Akteneinsicht dann an die Adresse kommt.
Und wenn du jetzt irgendwie mal ein Zeuge bist, wie ein paar Nazis irgendjemanden
auf der Straße verkloppen und du bist dann halt derjenige, der die Anzeige erstattet
hat oder du bist Zeuge, als Zeuge benannt, na herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Die haben auf jeden Fall über Akteneinsicht schon mal deine Adresse.
Und das ist häufig ein großes Problem.
Und jetzt hier ausgeweitet auf, du hast halt einen Koch, der ein Hurensohn ist und der arme Koch.
Ich frage mich nur, ob es nicht mittlerweile auch so ein Mittel einer,
ja nicht Anonymisierung, aber zumindest einer Adressanonymisierung gibt.
Dass man sagt, es gibt hier einen Kläger, der hat auch einen Namen,
aber dass die Adresse dann sozusagen nicht unmittelbar in den Akten ist.
Ja, das mag sein, aber das ist ja gerade gar nicht, also das wüsste ich nicht,
dass das effizient die Sorgen genommen hätte in letzter Zeit.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es das überhaupt gibt, dass es sozusagen.
Genau, deswegen reden wir auch einfach über das Gesetz, bei dem wir uns auskennen,
das ist hier das gegen digitale Gewalt und wenn Jura Alexander sagt,
es endet nur die Anonymität auf solchen Portalen, dann ist das ja genau das Problem.
Also ein Auskunftsanspruch wird immer auch missbraucht werden.
Ja und da muss man sich jetzt hier wirklich fragen, ob das ähm...
Also ob das, ob damit wirklich einer Sache Abhilfe geschaffen wird.
Und jetzt möchte ich mal über eine Sache noch spezifisch was sagen.
Ich habe jetzt hier viel über diesen Begriff Hurensohn gelacht,
weil das ja, der ja als schwere Beleidigung gilt, ja.
Und doch denke ich, am Ende wird es dann doch ehrlich gesagt mehr über diejenigen
aussagt, die diesen Begriff verwenden, als über die, die mit diesem Begriff bedacht werden.
Ja, also das ist für mich ungefähr so, wer diesen Begriff ernsthaft als Beleidigung
von anderen verwendet, hat sich doch eigentlich vollständig ins Abseits gestellt.
Also ist das so absolut unterste Kategorie.
Es gibt sicherlich eine Menge Dinge, die mich beleidigen würden,
aber eine derartige Titulierung würde mich immer in der Genugtuung lassen,
dass sich der andere gerade wirklich als absolute Unterschicht deklassiziert
hat, oder was? Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt.
Man kennt eure Worte nicht.
Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt. Das ist doch,
muss ich wirklich sagen, gerade wenn es ein Arbeitgeberportal oder sowas,
wenn da irgendjemand sagt, der ist ein Arschloch, ja gut, dann wird doch eigentlich
jede lesen können, aha, da wurde jemand gefeuert und wahrscheinlich offenbart
die Person da gerade auch genau, wieso sie gefeuert wurde.
Insofern weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich als Arbeitgeber auf Jobportalen das so
tragisch fände, wenn mich jemand aufs Übelste beleidigen würde.
Und ob ich dann sagen müsste, ich müsste jetzt, ich muss jetzt wissen,
wer das war und dieser Person einen auswischen oder ob ich es nicht viel schlimmer fände,
wenn da jemand irgendwelche, ja vielleicht unwahren, aber schwer nachweisbaren
oder schwer belegbaren Behauptungen tätigt, die nachhaltig meinem Beruf als
Arbeitgeber schaden, ne?
Bei der Koch ist ein Uhrensohn ist das ja, äh, ja, also.
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen! Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen!
Hast du das übrigens hier, den hab ich letztens im Podcast gehört.
Wusstest du, dass der Typ auch einfach nur Spaß gemacht hat?
Der hat sich da, also dieser, der, der, der, der wollte gar nicht Unreal Tournament spielen.
Der wollte ein lustiges, der wollte ein lustiges Video fürs Internet drehen
Und hat sich damit irgendwie über Jahre sein Leben zur Hölle gemacht,
weil ihm das keiner geglaubt hat, dass er das gestellt hat.
Nix kann man mehr glauben im Internet.
Naja, es war auf jeden Fall gelogen. Der wollte gar nicht Unreal Turtle mitspielen.
Das doch. Der Uhrensohn. Mensch, was hält der ein?
Naja, okay, also wir kommen zur ersten Meldung des Tages.
Also ich denke an Anonymität auf, gerade bei Portalen, Kommentarspalten und
so weiter, ist am Ende, und das ist glaube ich das Wichtige,
nicht die Wurzel des Übels, ja.
Auch das hatte ich ja in der vorletzten Folge schon gesagt, dass halt die Beschimpfungen
und so weiter trotzdem stattfinden.
Es gibt immer einen, der beleidigt und einen, der sich beleidigen lässt und
von solchen Begriffen würde ich mich zumindest nicht beleidigt fühlen.
Verstehst du ja auch alle nicht die Begriffe.
Ich verstehe nicht diese Idee von R-Begriff, die sich dahinter verbirgt, aber ok.
Sag das mal Dietmar Hopp.
Wer ist das?
Es war ja kurz vor Corona die Ausnahmesetzung, um nochmal kurz auf Fußball zurückzukommen
zwischen den Fans in Deutschland und der Fußball-Elite.
Das hat sich ja dann sozusagen alles genau auch wieder an diesem Begriff und an dieser,
angeblichen Beleidigung festgemacht und die Elite ist dann so komplett gegen
die Fans hoch eskaliert und dann wurde natürlich zurück eskaliert und mitten
in dieser Eskalation kam dann die Corona-Bremse,
sodass sozusagen dieser Fight noch ein bisschen unausgespielt wirkt.
Aber das war ja dann sozusagen das Ding, dass in allen Stadien Deutschlands
so sein Kotterpfeil im Fadenkreuz hochgehalten wurde mit der entsprechenden
textuellen Garnierung.
Ja, da finde ich das Fadenkreuz schlimmer als, aber wie gesagt,
ich weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Der, ich will noch ganz kurz hier diese Doku, von der ich sprach,
über Angry German Kid, die war von Zapp, ich hab mal den YouTube-Link mit reingetan.
Und das war also ja war tatsächlich ja also er hat er hat mich nachhaltig ja
oder war war mal sehr gut aufgezeichnet sehr gut dargestellt.
Seid vorsichtig wenn ihr was im Internet macht Leute das kann Folgen haben.
Ausgerechnet wir weißt du.
So Tim können wir zum ersten Thema kommen ich versuche hier die ganze Zeit ausnahmsweise
ausnahmsweise ja. Gut. So, fang an.
Corona-Warn-App is dead.
Wurde abgeschaltet, Corona ist vorbei, falls ihr es noch nicht gemerkt habt. Die Krise ist beendet.
Und wie anfangs auch angekündigt, Wurde diese App, die ja nun dafür geschaffen
wurde und auch bei uns ausführlich von Anfang an diskutiert wurde,
wurde die Infrastruktur dafür, die erforderlich ist,
damit die App überhaupt funktionieren kann, auf den Telefon ausgeschaltet für Deutschland,
weil auch diese App sozusagen offiziell disabled wurde,
also die deutsche zuständige Gesundheitsbehörde hat den Betriebssystem-Providern,
Also Apple, Google vor allem gesagt, so wir betrachten die Krise im Kern als
beendet und wir beenden jetzt dieses Tracking und damit wird dann auch das Subsystem ausgeschaltet,
sodass eben das nicht mehr weiter betrieben werden kann.
Sie haben vor allem die Warn-Funktion ausgeschaltet.
Sie haben gesagt, wir warnen nicht mehr und damit braucht man auch nicht mehr
das Tracking oder Tracing zu machen.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn du jetzt da anrufst und sagst, hier ich hab Corona,
ich will warnen, dann kriegst du halt keinen Anschluss unter dieser Nummer.
Und Apple hat dann auch diese Funktionalität und Google und Apple deaktivieren die dann jetzt auch.
Das weiß ich gar nicht. Lauterbach sagt ja, löscht die App mal nicht.
Es kann gut sein, dass wir die irgendwann wieder nutzen möchten.
Also, ob für Covid oder für andere Infektionskrankheiten.
Aber auf jeden Fall wird jetzt der Betrieb, dieser Warnbetrieb,
geht jetzt in den Winterschlaf.
Lauterbach begründet das mit,
das macht keinen Sinn bei der geringen Inzidenz, die wir zurzeit haben.
Außerdem gibt es eine hohe Bevölkerungsimmunität, sodass die Krankheit nicht
mehr so schwer verläuft.
Ja, da scheint er recht zu haben. Auf jeden Fall höre ich seltener von Leuten,
die von der Seuche dahingerafft werden.
Oder zumindest Verläufe haben, die ihnen schwerer zu schaffen machen.
Tja, schade natürlich, dass jetzt irgendwie, also das Traurige mit dem nicht
unbedingt Ende der Pandemie, das ist ja nicht, oder nein, Ende der pandemischen
Phase, Beginn der endemischen Phase.
Das Traurige ist, dass jetzt irgendwie diese ganzen, also dass alle denken,
es wäre immer so gewesen und nicht verstehen, dass wir uns das herbei geimpft haben.
Das finde ich schon ein bisschen bedauerlich, wie das jetzt rückwirkend auch
umgeschrieben wird oder umgedeutet wird, was da passiert ist.
Ja gut aber unabhängig davon ist jetzt sozusagen dieser Prozess dieser digitalen
Verfolgung oder gegenseitigen Warnung vielmehr abgeschaltet worden und in all
diesem ganzen Zeitraum ist halt nichts datenschutztechnisch bedenkliches passiert mit dieser App.
Nee, da haben wir uns ja auch stark für eingesetzt, ja also, genau.
Und zwar nicht weil irgendjemand keinen Fehler gemacht hat, sondern eben weil
es gar nicht ging, weil man einfach auf ein Modell gesetzt hat,
was das eben gar nicht erst erlaubt.
Und das ist wirklich, also nicht irgendwas möchte,
dass das von dieser Maßnahme in Erinnerung bleibt,
dass es oft, nicht immer, aber oft möglich ist einfach Modelle zu wählen,
die einfach von vornherein gar kein Missbrauchspotenzial bieten oder wo das
zumindest in einem Maße eingeschränkt wird, soweit es eben technisch möglich ist.
Jetzt mal so ganz allgemein gedacht auch bei anderen Systemen.
Zielgerichtete, sinnvolle Systeme bauen spart Ärger und tja,
es ist halt eine, ich finde es auch, ja,
ich meine, ich vermisse die Diskussion nicht, darum, ja, aber sie war mal interessant
und es ist schon schön, dass es eine, ja, dass man es auch mal zeigen konnte, ne, dass man mal,
dass wir es einmal wirklich geschafft haben, zu zeigen, hier,
pass auf, man kann dieses Ziel auf elegantem, sinnvollem Weg erreichen und man
muss dafür nicht alles über Bord werfen.
Es ist nicht wieder der Datenschutz, der alle tötet, sondern man kann ein sinnvolles
System bauen. Das war's schon.
War schon ganz gut, was aber natürlich auch nicht die ganzen Überwachungshardler,
denn nix schlimm genug sein kann, irgendwie davon abgehalten hätte dann zu sagen,
diese Warn-App, die funktioniert, aber sie ist ein,
das war das Dümmste, ich glaub das war Dieter Nuhr oder so,
also auf jeden Fall Niveau Dieter Nuhr, dass die Corona-Warn-App ein zahnloser
Papiertiger wär, weil man damit jetzt keinen strafen kann, weil man damit niemanden
zu Hause festhalten kann.
Und denkst dir so, welcher Vollidiot installiert sich denn eine App auf sein
Handy, die sich irgendwie in eine Fußfesse verwechselt oder die sich irgendwie
an die… also da herrschen auch immer Vorstellungen vor bei diesen Leuten.
Das ist wirklich… ach man ey.
So ist die Welt. Aber ist ja auch schwierig mit der Technik.
Aber können wir ja gleich mal zum nächsten Thema wechseln?
Ne, bleiben wir mal kurz bei dem Thema.
Wieso?
Die Corona-Warn-App hat 220 Millionen Euro gekostet.
Ja.
Über diese Zeit. Das ist natürlich schon auch eine ganze Menge Geld.
Also dafür, dass die, dafür, dass die, diese Location-Tracing-API von Apple
und Google schon fertig war und du eigentlich nur noch dieses Warnsystem da drum bauen musstest.
Naja gut es ist ja sehr viel Geld also einerseits in die App geflossen aber
ich glaube das allermeiste eher so in diese Telefonhotlines um das sozusagen zu machen.
Das war quasi eher der Mangel der Digitalisierung unseres Gesundheitssystems
was dann auch durchgeschlagen hat. Die ganzen Anbindungen die dann erstmal geschaffen werden mussten.
Also das war auch Lehrgeld. Andererseits das ist jetzt ein bisschen müßig,
das so gegeneinander aufzurechnen, aber ich denke bei der Betrachtung der Mittel,
die hierfür aufgewendet wurden, muss man mal gucken, welche Kosten insgesamt
so entstanden sind und man muss natürlich auch nochmal rechnen,
was das Vermeiden von Infektionen durch eine effektive Infektion dann wiederum
an Folgekosten auch verhindert haben kann.
Einfach Leute die da nicht krank werden, keinen entsprechenden Wirtschaftsausfall
nach sich ziehen oder entsprechende Krankheitszahlungen etc.
Ja aber ich glaube, also ich finde das auch wichtig was du sagst,
das hätte man billiger hinbekommen, wenn man eine halbwegs sinnvolle digitalisierte
Gesellschaft gehabt hätte.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel das jetzt so in anderen Ländern,
ob die da nennenswert billiger rausgekommen sind, das wäre natürlich nochmal interessant.
Da habe ich auch keinerlei Informationen zu.
Aber irgendwie wurde, irgendwie haben wir es überstanden ohne gechippt zu werden,
sind nicht alle im September gestorben, haben, also das war dann doch alles
schon irgendwie, ich sag mal, wenn man, wenn man jetzt mal so die Vorhersagekraft,
Der, das ist ein bisschen doof, ne?
Aber wenn man mal so gehört hat, was die vernünftigen Leute sagen,
dann haben die auf Dauer dann doch irgendwie Recht behalten, ne?
Da brauchte man gar nicht die Leute mit den Schauspielern.
Wo wir aber jetzt bei dem Punkt sind, darf ich das Thema jetzt wechseln?
Ja, wenn du möchtest, das kannst du. Weil ich hatte mir gerade so eine schöne
Überleitung zurechtgelegt,
weil wir ja darüber sprachen, dass man ja technische Maßnahmen,
die man so unternimmt, auch im Hinblick auf ihre datenschutzrechtlichen und
sonstigen Fallouts untersuchen muss, bevor man politische Entscheidungen fällt.
Das ist eine gute Überleitung.
Und das bringt uns natürlich wieder zur Chat-Kontrolle, wo ja Thomas letzte
Woche eigentlich relativ optimistische Ausblicke geliefert hat,
aber es ist ja nicht so, dass die Diskussion schon beendet wäre.
Nee, aber es, ja, jetzt hat der Bundesjustizminister Buschmann,
hat jetzt mit mehreren Landeskolleginnen einen Brief formuliert,
in dem er auf Gutachten des Juristischen Dienstes des Rates und des Wissenschaftlichen
Dienstes des Europäischen Parlaments Bezug nimmt,
die beide klar machen, dass die Pläne der Chat-Kontrolle nicht mit Artikel 7
und 8 der Grundrechte-Charta der EU vereinbar sind.
Da geht es um den Recht auf Schutz des Privatlebens und privater Kommunikation
sowie Schutz personenbezogener Daten.
Außerdem sagt er sogar, die Verordnung kann sich negativ auf die Verfolgung
von Kindesmissbrauch im Netz auswirken,
etwa wegen fälschlich gemeldeter Inhalte,
Überlastung der Strafverfolgungsbehörden, ja, also im Prinzip alle Argumente,
die jetzt sag ich mal, die sind alle nicht neu,
das heißt aber nicht, dass sie falsch oder langweilig werden,
sondern ganz im Gegenteil, sie sind richtig, ja, und der Buschmann fordert jetzt
mit seinen europäischen Amtskollegen, fordert seine europäischen Amtskollegen
auf, sich in diese Diskussion einzubringen.
Die von den Innenministerien der meisten EU-Mitgliedsstaaten geführt wird.
Also der sagt auch, passt mal auf Leute, was eure Innenminister gerade machen,
das ist nicht akzeptabel und wendet sich an die, an seine Justizministerinnen,
Kolleginnen in der Europäischen Union.
Und das ist natürlich schon eine, ja, ein ordentliches Vorgehen.
Das macht er gut. Ja, hat lange gedauert.
Aber wenn man erstmal so, was hat der 3000 Follower auf Soundcloud,
da hat man auch einfach direkt ein ganz anderes Selbstvertrauen in sich selber
als Justizminister, ja? War der doch, oder?
Ja, mehr als du, ne?
Mal gucken, ich weiß gar nicht, ich schau mal, ob mein Aufruf hier letztes Mal was gebracht hat.
Ach ja.
Gar nix, Alter, was haben wir denn hier für Fans?
Ich weiß, dass du immer noch für deine große DJ und Musikkarriere träumst,
aber vielleicht ist das auch nicht der richtige Weg für dich.
Wenn es ein raumbildendes Hackmittel gibt, dann kriegen wir direkt die Kommentare.
Aber wenn es mal darum geht, mal eben so einen Provinz DJ auf Soundcloud zu
überholen, dann lassen die uns hängen.
Hättest du mal einen Social Media Kurs zu Ende gemacht.
Hat der Marco Busch mal einen Social Media Kurs gemacht?
Nee, du. Du musst immer einen zu Ende machen.
Also, Deutschland, Liechtenstein, Luxemburg, Österreich und Schweiz haben diesen Brief formuliert.
Ich glaube, ich bin falsch davon ausgegangen, dass es Landesjustizministerinnen
wären, aber es sind von anderen Ländern, nicht von anderen Bundesländern.
Und das ist schon nicht schlecht, dass er, dass er sich da einbringt.
Also kudos an Marco Buschmann. Ja muss man einfach mal, hat er richtig gemacht,
bisschen spät, aber immerhin.
So, dann haben wir, unser Spezialfreund,
hier der, also Augustus Intelligence,
das sind auch wieder so Sachen, das haben wir schon wieder vergessen,
das hast du ja schon wieder vergessen, dass Guttenberg und Amthor ja für ein
Unternehmen lobbyiert haben,
in das sie selber investiert hatten, beziehungsweise in dem sie angestellt waren.
Bei Guttenberg, der ist ja adelig,
die haben irgendwie Geld in dieses Unternehmen investiert Und dann hat Karl
Theodor zu Guttenberg bei Angela Merkel sich für das Unternehmen eingesetzt,
in das er selber investiert hat, was auch so, what the fuck,
so warum ist sowas überhaupt, also ich meine, selbst wenn das legal ist,
ja, also selbst wenn das jetzt nicht legal ist, ja, können wir uns wenigstens
darauf einigen, dass das ganz schön schäbig ist, so?
Also vielleicht, wenn wir schon irgendwie nicht mit der Härte des Gesetzes,
ja, Können wir wenigstens mit der Härte aller Schäbigkeit das verurteilen?
Auf jeden Fall ich würde auch Inter Mailand warnen, wenn der Amthor vorbeikommt
und ihnen einen neuen Trikotsponsor vorschlägt, der zahlt auch nicht.
Besser nochmal jemanden anrufen, wie aus anderen Kreisen.
Tja dann und genau dieses Unternehmen ist dann pleite gegangen,
es kommt ja noch dazu, dann haben sie sich irgendwie gesagt,
ja der Amthor hat ja nicht dafür lobbyiert, Maaßen war ja auch noch da,
der Maaßen hat die angeblich beraten.
Was für eine Kombi, Amthor Maaßen und irgendwie, guten Tag echt,
wirklich, chaoten gegen dich.
August Hannig war auch noch da, August Hannig,
XPND-Chef, ja der hat beraten, so und das kleine Startup hat 30 Mitarbeiter,
da waren wie 100 Millionen drin, oder nee, doch da waren über 100 Millionen drin.
Und jetzt ist dann ein Insolvenzverwalter und sagt,
ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck,
dass das hier eine Betrugsmasche ist,
weil die haben ja behauptet, sie hätten 50 Millionen Dollar Startkapital und
außerdem Zugang zu wichtigen Kryptotechnologien.
Habe ich auch, habe ich auch.
OMSSL, PGP, alles. RSA, ich habe richtig krasse, ECDSA, ich habe richtig fundamentale
Kryptotechnologien, habe ich auf meinem Computer.
Wir sind die Meister der elliptischen Kurven.
Ja, dann haben sie nämlich gesagt, sie würden das Geld,
Also der würde Geld einbringen und Rechenzentren, die dann Bitcoins herstellen
und der Firma den Eintritt ins Krypto-Geschäft ermöglichen,
was natürlich auch lustig ist, ich meine, wenn du 50 Millionen US-Dollar hast,
kannst du auch einfach Bitcoin kaufen, dann bist du ins Krypto-Geschäft eingestiegen,
viel Spaß, dann wäre es schneller vorbei gewesen.
Vor allem sagt dir dann nachher keiner, das war ein Scam, weil das Geld ist ja wirklich weg.
Aber in dem Fall haben sie irgendwie mit falschen Versprechungen nochmal 35
Millionen eingesammelt und jetzt sagt er,
naja, scheint mir so, dass ihr das von vornherein darauf ausgelegt war,
die Leute zu täuschen und denen einfach zu sagen, hier, künstliche Intelligenz,
Blockchain, ja, da gibt man Kohle.
Und naja, jetzt sagt er halt,
naja, der Amthor, der ja dort Direktor war, also irgendwie Aufsichtsrat,
der hätte halt genau das kontrollieren müssen.
Dass er sagt, naja, Amthor, du warst doch als Aufsichtsrat über diese Missstände
informiert und du warst auch darüber informiert,
dass den Investoren weit mehr versprochen wurde, als irgendwie das Unternehmen hatte, ja.
Und als Aufsichtsrat musst du natürlich dem Interesse der Investoren gehorchen
und nicht dem Kontrollgremium dieses Unternehmens.
Und wenn du sagst, ach ja, AI, Crypto, Hulu, Hulu, dann hast du natürlich was falsch gemacht, ja.
Und ja, der wirft ja jetzt also dem Amthor vor und das ist aber zivilrechtlich,
also das ist nicht strafrechtlich.
Wollen wir mal schauen.
Aber ich meine es ist schon, ey das ist doch so klar,
das ist einfach so ein Schema,
was einfach, das klingt, das riecht einfach schlecht,
da wird einfach irgendwie mit dicker Kohle irgendeine Firma aufgesetzt,
die irgendwie toll klingt.
Mit buzzwords um sich wirft so und dann geht einfach ein Großteil dieser investierten
Kohle geht nicht in Produkte oder richtige Arbeit oder so,
nee das wird dann einfach schön in die Taschen geworfen so hier bis in den Aufsichtsrat,
so wir müssen auch einmal im Jahr müssen wir ganz wichtig wichtig dann in den
USA auch so ein Aufsichtsrat Meeting haben und so und das kostet natürlich und
das wird natürlich auch alles vergütet.
Da gab es ja jetzt auch gerade einen ähnlichen Skandal in Großbritannien,
ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast.
Da gibt es ja schon seit längerem eine aus diesem Anti-Brexit-Movement herausgeborene
Gruppe, die zu verfolgen ich euch nur empfehlen kann, weil die wirklich großartige Arbeit machen.
Led by Donkeys heißt die Gruppe,
die sind durch verschiedenste Aktionen aufgefallen,
unter anderem haben sie mit so fetten Beamern,
so Anti-Brexit Botschaften auf die Klippen von Dover projiziert,
aber auch zu anderen Gelegenheiten in Straßen und so weiter und immer wieder
auch coole Aktionen gemacht. Sehr unterschiedlicher Art.
Und was die jetzt gemacht haben ist, sie haben in Südkorea, haben die so eine
Scheinfirma gegründet,
die einfach auch nur bla bla war, die es gar nicht so richtig gab,
aber die irgendwie total wichtig wichtig klang und haben dann sprachlich begabte
Menschen ans Telefon gesetzt,
die sich dann einfach mal so im britischen Parlamentsestablishment,
insbesondere bei den Tories, nicht nur bei den Tories, Aber nur bei den Tories
haben sie dann auch wirklich Abnehmer gefunden,
so ja hier wir sind ja Unternehmen sowieso und wir bräuchten dann mal jemanden
der bei uns da irgendwie brät und so weiter und das haben sie dann alles mitgeschnitten,
diese Telefonate und ja und die dann so ja naja.
Tagessatz, ich weiß nicht mehr genau was die Zahlen waren aber sowas in der
Größenordnung von 50.000 Pfund und so weiter.
Ja das ist ja alles kein Problem und dann fliegen wir sie ein und so und dann
haben die halt solche irrsinnigen Summen genannt und die wurden dann einfach
so akzeptiert und die dachten natürlich wirklich so das wäre so ihr Ding.
So kann ich jetzt grad die Namen nicht runterbeten, ich glaub Dominik Raab war
dabei, also auch so ein paar der prominenteren Tories.
Und also wirklich völlig ohne drüber nachzudenken, ohne sich auch nennenswert
schlau zu machen oder auch nur irgendwie im Verdacht erstmal,
also ich meine du lässt dich da auf irgendjemand ein, ruft einfach so einer
an, bietet dir irgendwie fett Kohle und dann geht's hier um wilde Tagessätze,
das scheint so ein normales Geschäft zu sein, also das war wirklich der Eindruck
den man davon bekommen hat.
Dass das so eine normale Sache war für die, dass sie das überhaupt nicht als
besonders auffällig, weißt du?
Ja da ist mal wieder einer der ganz viel Geld hat, wo ich einmal im Jahr irgendwie
zu so einer Alibi-Sitzung hinfliege und mir schön First Class hier den Popo
tätscheln lasse im Flugzeug um dann da irgendwie ein bisschen rumzusitzen und
ansonsten geht's halt im Wesentlichen um meinen Einfluss.
Und das ist natürlich so dieses ding und um auf
deutschland wieder zurückzukommen ich weiß nicht wie steht es jetzt gerade mit
der annahme der korruptions Deklarationen der un ist glaube ich in deutschland
immer noch nicht umgesetzt worden also Das ist so ein echtes problem und es
gibt einfach da leute die sind einfach zu nah an an solchen menschen und Leider
muss man immer wieder feststellen,
ich würde auf keinen Fall behaupten, die werden die einzigen,
aber mir ist es dann doch alles immer ein bisschen zu CDU lastig alles.
Ja, die sind irgendwie nicht weit, wenn sowas kommt, die sind ja erstaunlich.
Das hatte ich gestern, da habe ich kurz in so eine, wie heißt das,
Anne Will reingeschaut, wo dann auch sich jetzt die CDU gerade aufregt,
was werfen sie dem Habeck gerade vor?
Sein Staatssekretär hat einen Posten zu vergeben gehabt und der Typ,
der den bekommen hat, ist sein Trauzeuge.
Ja, sowas.
Und darüber regt sich jetzt die CDU auf.
Also ausgerechnet die CDU und da sagte auch der Lars Klingweiler dann so,
kann er irgendwie gar nicht verstehen, wie die CDU sich traut da irgendwie großes Mäxchen zu machen,
weil dafür sollte man ja eigentlich erwarten, dass ausgerechnet die CDU bei
derartigen Angelegenheiten echt so relativ kleine Brötchen backt.
Aber die stellen sich da auf die Hinterbeine und machen einen riesen Theater.
Und das funktioniert halt deshalb, weil natürlich bei den Anständigen so etwas
noch tatsächlich ein Problem ist.
Weil du Leute, die, sagen wir mal, politisch sich irgendwo in der Nähe von Robert
Habeck bewegen, die wirklich noch ein Problem mit haben.
Während sich die CDUler natürlich denken so, also es ist einfach bitter.
Also man muss mehr darauf achten, welche Angriffsflächen die anderen nicht haben, aber du hast.
Und ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen das, was bei der CDU so ein bisschen
der Sport zu sein scheint.
Die haben einfach alle so davon überzeugt oder so daran gewöhnt,
dass sie alle immer überall im Rudel auftauchen, dass sich da keiner mehr drüber
wundert, was das für eine Gruppe ist.
Ja, ach ja.
Ich glaub bei dem Abenteuer muss man wirklich einfach sagen, der ist einfach doof.
Bei dem muss man wirklich sagen, das kann auch einfach Doofheit gewesen sein,
aber man sollte ja niemals mit Boshaftigkeit erklären, was man auch mit Doofheit
begründen kann, insofern würde ich dem Abenteuer hier Benefit of the doubt geben, aber okay.
Was aber wirklich mit Boshaftigkeit zu erklären ist, Übergänge kriegen wir heute
hin Tim, ich hab jetzt auch einen guten hingekriegt, hast du gemerkt?
Wow, irre, find ich nicht gut. Ja mach mal weiter, dann kann ich das selbst
beurteilen. Erstmal loben, guck mal mein geiler Übergang, mein geiler Übergang,
wenn du das am DJ-Pult machst, weißt du?
Mach ich immer.
Das ist vorbei. Erstmal schön T-Shirt ausziehen, Hände hoch,
guck mal, geiler Übergang. Und so Platte zu Ende.
Sorry, sorry. Woher weißt du das?
Es ist immer das gleiche.
Also Google-Font-Abmahnungen. Wir haben es auch darüber besprochen,
dass hier diese, wie hieß die, IG-Datenschutz, wo irgendwie so ein Opfer die
ganze Zeit über das Internet gesurft ist und überall,
wo ein Google-Font war, irgendwie Raubmord-Schmerzen erlitt,
und sich dann gezwungen, satt tausendfache Abmahnungen über das Internet gepeinigt wurde,
Während er irgendwie Restaurants und Kneipen 500 Kilometer von seinem Wohnort
entfernt, eine nach der anderen durchgegoogelt hat.
Also komplette Schema, komplette Masche.
Und die haben ja dann Abmahnung versendet, weil Leute Google Font eingeblendet hatten.
Davor hatten wir auch gewarnt, weil es eben die Sota gab, was gesagt hat,
dass hier ist nicht die adäquate Methode mit dem Google Font,
man kann die auch selber hosten.
Ja gut, ich hab auch, würde jetzt sagen kann man, aber wir haben natürlich auch,
es gibt schon auch andere größere Probleme, die wir haben, aber okay.
Gesetz ist Gesetz und es gab eben das Urteil, dass das Einbinden von Google-Fonds
eben nicht gerechtfertigt ist. Also haben die dann eine Abmahn-Schema gefahren
und haben irgendwie, ich glaube, so etwas über 100 Euro von den Leuten abgemahnt, ja.
Und dann hat sich dagegen jemand gewehrt.
Und zwar haben die eine negative Feststellungsklage gemacht,
das ist also quasi, die haben geklagt,
dass dieser Anspruch, der gegen sie erhoben wird, als nicht gerechtfertigt anerkannt
wird, also die haben auf Feststellung geklagt, dass das nicht geht.
Ja, also die haben nicht nur gesagt, wir zahlen nicht, stick the gid,
sondern die haben gesagt, okay, wir lassen jetzt auch richterlich feststellen,
dass der Anspruch, den du da erhebst, rechtsmissbräuchlich ist.
Und das hat das Landgericht München oder was war das jetzt? Mal gucken.
Das sind Fragen. Landgericht München, ja.
Genau, Landgericht München hat dann gesagt, hier in seinem Urteil,
Es ist nicht Sinn und Zweck des allgemeinen Persönlichkeitsrechts oder der Datenschutzvorgaben
nach der Datenschutzgrundverordnung, Personen eine Erwerbsquelle zu verschaffen,
wegen behaupteter Verletzungen ihres allgemeinen Persönlichkeitsrechts.
Weiter, wer einen Verstoß gegen sein Persönlichkeitsrecht gezielt provoziert,
Um daraus hernach Ansprüche zu
begründen, verstößt gegen das Verbot selbstwidersprüchlichen Verhaltens.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es verboten ist, sich selber zu widersprechen,
aber es ist schon relativ klar, dass das eben hier rechtsmissbräuchlich war.
Und es ist auch sehr schön, dass das Urteil, dass das Gericht das hier geurteilt hat.
Ich bin gespannt, ob die anderen, die Geschädigten, vielleicht auch ihr Geld mal zurückbekommen.
Also, es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Menschen,
die sich davon haben einschüchtern lassen und bezahlt haben und da würde mich
jetzt mal, also ich fände es jetzt schon schön, wenn die jetzt einfach mal,
wenn die mal dazu verurteilt würden, das Geld auch zurückzugeben, ja?
Die haben ja mindestens 100.000,
Abmahnungen versendet und damit hätten sie bis zu 340.000 Euro erzielen können.
Weil vermutlich, also und zugrunde liegt, vermutlich zwei Prozent der Angeschriebenen
den geforderten Betrag von 170 Euro gezahlt hätten.
Und das sagt das Gericht, das ist ein bisschen zu niedrig.
Die könnten natürlich jetzt alle auch zurückklagen. Sehr erfolgreich.
Ja. Kilian, achso, man sollte noch sagen, wie die heißen. Berliner Rechtsanwalt
Kilian Lenhardt und der Mandant Martin Ismail, steht hier.
Von denen war das. Nur falls mal jemand einen Rechtsanwalt sucht oder einen Mandanten.
Alter, was, ehrlich, das ist auch, ich mein, sowas nimmt einem natürlich auch den Spaß weg, ne?
Dann hast du irgendwie halbwegs vernünftige Gesetze, ja, bei Google Fonds,
dieser ganze DSGVO, das kam halt ein paar Jahre zu spät, ist halt leider so gewesen, ne?
Aber dass du dann auch noch so Abmahn-Assis hast, die dann natürlich auch wieder
die ganze Branche in Verruf bringen, also die Datenschutzbranche,
da ist der Datenschutz schon echt ein gebeuteltes Kind.
Okay, letzte Meldung. Wir alle kennen und lieben AirTags und wie heißt das bei Android?
Weiß nicht, hat Google schon so ein Produkt?
Klar, die haben das genauso. Bei Google heißt das, keine Ahnung,
gibt es aber auch. Also da müssen wir mal gucken, wie das heißt bei Google.
Pixel Finder.
Das ist aber ein sehr eleganter Name. Wirklich Pixel Finder?
Das sehe ich hier so.
Ich muss mich erstmal durch die Cookie-Banner durchklicken.
Aber ich glaube, so ein Name wird hier gefeatured.
Keine Ahnung. Frag mich nicht zu Android, da weiß ich nichts drüber.
Ich auch nicht so wirklich.
Also AirTags, haben wir schon öfter mal drüber gesprochen.
Kleine Geräte, die, achso, eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht nochmal in dieser
Sendung auch drüber zu sprechen, die sich erstaunlich nah von dem,
was sie tun, an der Corona-Warn-App bewegen.
Nämlich die ganze Zeit wechselnde Identifier-Beacons aussenden,
die für jemanden, der sie so erst mal sieht, zunächst zufällig aussehen.
Bei Find My ist es nicht ganz so zufällig. Also man kann schon noch erkennen,
dass der Beacon von dem gleichen Gerät kommt.
Aber es ist im Prinzip eine kleine Corona-Warn-App, funktioniert genauso,
sendet also die ganze Zeit Signale aus.
Und jetzt passiert es so, dass wenn diese Geräte, also wenn du jetzt so ein AirTag hast,
sag mal, du tust sie jetzt an deinen Schlüssel oder an dein Portemonnaie oder
so, und dann weiß dein iPhone beispielsweise, redet dann so mit denen und weiß immer, die sind da.
Und wenn du jetzt, wenn du das Ding verlierst, dann kannst du dir beispielsweise
einstellen, dass wenn dein iPhone längere Zeit nichts mehr von dem Ding gehört
hat, dass es dir sagt, hör mal, du hast da etwas zurückgelassen,
du hast deinen Autoschlüssel zuhause gelassen oder so.
Das gleiche kannst du inzwischen auch mit deinem iPad, Zweit-iPhone,
Uhr, AirPods und so weiter machen, dass du diese Geräte wieder findest.
Und die sind dann eben weltweit ortbar, solange sie Strom haben und solange
sie sich in der Reichweite von anderen Apple-Geräten befinden,
die wiederum eine Internetverbindung haben.
So ein Airport hat halt kein Internet, der hat nur Bluetooth,
aber so die iPhones, die da dann vorbeigehen.
AirTag. Genau, AirTag. Ein Airport auch, aber ein AirTag auch nicht, ne?
Und dann gehen die iPhones, die da vorbeigehen, die sammeln halt diese Signale
ein, schicken an Apple und sagen, guck mal hier, ich bin ungefähr da und da
und ich habe gerade diese Codes eingesammelt und dann weiß Apple,
ach ja, ok, super, die Dinger sind, das Ding ist da und da.
So, unglaublich praktisch, ja. Wir hatten ja Lilith Wittmann hier in der Sendung,
die so ein Ding mal an den Verfassungsschutz geschickt hat, um zu beweisen,
dass der Briefkasten, den sie da hatten, vom Verfassungsschutz ist.
Und damit kommen wir natürlich dann auch zu den Missbrauchsmöglichkeiten dieser
Dinge. Es gibt erstmal natürlich eine ganze Menge sinnvoller Anwendungszwecke.
Keine Ahnung, klebst du halt einen an deinem Auto oder bringst du einen an deinem
Fahrrad an. Koffer, Schlüssel. Abkoffer, Schlüssel, Portemonnaie,
Autoschlüssel, im Rucksack einfach mal so ein Ding.
Fernbedienung, die verlegt man gerne mal.
Ich hab keinen Fernseher, aber okay.
Muss nicht eine Fernbedienung für einen Fernseher sein, also allgemein Fernbedienungen,
die sozusagen mobil sind und die man dann aber auch wiederfinden will.
Kinder? Die tragen ja schon ihre Telefone durch die Gegend.
Also super praktische Dinger.
Wie viele hast du im Einsatz jetzt sozusagen?
Vier.
Vier nur? Wow.
Ja ich hab ja nicht so viele Kinder wie du.
Und jetzt haben die aber natürlich,
die sind winzig klein und haben natürlich jetzt eine, ja, also plötzlich wird die Möglichkeit,
jemanden, dessen Bewegungen zu überwachen, so ein bisschen einfacher zugänglich, ja?
Das gab es schon immer oder gab es gibt es schon lange GPS Tracker kannst du dir kaufen,
ist ein Gerät mit Marco schickt alle so und so viel Minuten eine SMS oder hat
Internetverbindung oder so und sagt wo es sich gerade befindet geht,
aber die waren so ein bisschen klobig, die brauchen ein GPS,
funktionieren nicht im Keller und jetzt hat halt Apple aus dem Nichts heraus
aus seinen iPhones im Prinzip so ein Ortungsnetzwerk für Geräte und Und da kommen
natürlich Menschen auf die Idee zu sagen,
wenn ich so ein AirTag habe, was kostet der? 35 Euro oder so, ne?
Und ich möchte wissen, wo jemand wohnt, ja? Dann werfe ich das Ding einfach
der Person in die Tasche und kann herausfinden, wo die abends nach Hause geht.
Oder wo die heute Abend noch hingeht,
oder ob die nach Hause geht oder vielleicht nicht nach Hause geht.
Also diese ganzen Überwachungsmöglichkeiten, die Menschen potenziell gegeneinander verwenden.
Und das hat natürlich ein hohes Missbrauchspotenzial und ist für viele Menschen eine sehr...
Beunruhigende Realität, dass das überhaupt möglich ist, ja? Und Fälle,
dass es passiert ist, werden natürlich ausreichend berichtet.
Natürlich ist das immer noch ein winzig kleiner Prozent-Satz von der Anwendung
dieser Geräte, die eben zu sicherlich 99,9 Prozent legitim verwendet werden.
Aber das ist natürlich für die Leute, die mit so einem Ding gestalkt wurden, Nur ein geringer Trost.
Als die Dinger auf den Markt kamen, hatte Apple zumindest sich darüber auch
schon Gedanken gemacht und haben sie gesagt, okay, wir machen,
wenn die Dinger längere Zeit von ihrem Besitzer getrennt sind,
dann fangen die an zu piepen.
Was mich zum Beispiel total nervt, weil ich gerne an meinem Wohnmobil so ein
Ding anbringen würde, aber weil ich mich längere Zeit von meinem Wohnmobil entferne,
würde dieses AirTag dann eben potenzielle Diebe eh warnen, ja?
Naja, kommt drauf an, wo du's anbringst.
Ja, und kommt drauf an, ja, oder ob ich's halt den Lautsprecher da drin kaputtbohre, ne?
Aber eine zweite Funktionalität haben die auch noch.
Und das ist, wenn sich so etwas längere Zeit mit dir mitbewegt,
dann sagt dein iPhone, ein AirTag bewegt sich längere Zeit mit dir mit.
Und das ist mir auch schon öfter passiert.
Beispielsweise beim längeren Abendspaziergang mit einem Kollegen,
der Airpods hatte und dann sagte mein iPhone irgendwann, pass mal auf,
du bewegst dich die ganze Zeit und mit dir reisen Airpods mit.
Interessanterweise hatte der gleiche Kollege schon mal meine Airpods mit nach
Hause genommen und ich stand abends bei ihm vor der Tür und hab gesagt, Airpods wieder her.
Also wir haben so eine Airpods-Sache abgelaufen, ja.
So kommt man sich auch näher dann.
Ja, ich wusste auch nicht, dass er da wohnt und hab dann irgendwie irgendwann
relativ spät dann gecheckt, dass seine Tür nah am Stand, den ich kannte.
Das heißt, oder was mir das auch letztens ein paar mal passiert ist beim Zugfahren,
dass das iPhone dann sagte, hier ein AirTag ist längere Zeit mit dir mitgereist.
So, also sie haben so Stalking, Anti-Stalking Mechanismen eingebaut,
die basieren aber natürlich darauf, dass dein iPhone weiß,
dass die Signale, die es da so vor sich hin empfängt, immer von dem gleichen AirTag kommen.
Also anders als bei der Corona-Warn-App, wo sich diese Identifier ja immer ändern
und nicht mehr so wirklich zurückführbar sind,
ist es in dem Fall schon zumindest erkennbar, dass ein spezifisches AirTag sich
längere Zeit in deiner Nähe aufhält.
Und da setzt er natürlich auch die Möglichkeit an, das System zu umgehen,
weil das Protokoll, was die Dinger sprechen, ist notgedrungen nicht schwer.
Und du kannst, mein ehemaliger Kollege Fabian Bräunlein hat das schon kurz,
nachdem die Dinger rauskommen, gebaut, gab es irgendwie einen Nachbau dieses
Protokolls und dann hat er einfach ein AirTag gebaut,
das jetzt ein bisschen klobiger ist, was aber einfach andauernd seinen Identifier
ändert, sodass er in seinem Find My de facto, sagen wir mal, zehn AirTags hat.
Und dieses eine AirTag rotiert einfach die ganze Zeit zehn durch,
sodass du, wenn du dann auf deiner Find My Liste guckst, siehst du halt zehn
Locations, musst einfach die jüngste nehmen und weißt, da befindet sich das Gerät gerade.
Dadurch, dass er aber die ganze Zeit seinen Identifier ändert,
wird keiner mehr alarmiert, dass sein AirTag in der Nähe hat,
was sich lange mit ihm mitbewegt.
Also man kann das auch immer wieder umgehen. Jetzt gab es aber eigentlich folgendes
Problem, als die Dinger auf den Markt kamen.
Apple hat diese wunderschönen Anti-Tracking-Funktionen, Anti-Stalking-Funktionen
eingebaut in sein Betriebssystem und hat gesagt, ja, und für Android machen wir euch eine App.
Da machen wir euch eine App. Da könnt ihr, wenn ihr wollt, die anmachen und
dann sagt ihr euch auch, was in eurer Nähe ist, gerade oder nicht.
Was natürlich so ein bisschen schlechterer Schutz für Android-Nutzer ist.
Und deswegen haben die sich jetzt zusammengesetzt und haben einen,
also Google und Apple haben einen gemeinsamen Vorschlag für einen Industriestandard
eingereicht, der eben die missbrüchliche Nutzung weiter einschränken soll.
Und irgendwie Chipolo, UFi, Samsung, Tile, Pebblebee, also weitere Hersteller
haben auch angekündigt, dass sie da mitmachen.
Dadurch soll dann eben auch zum Beispiel ein Samsung-Handy mit einem Android-Betriebssystem
in AirTag erkennen können und umgekehrt.
So, die sollen also piepen können und was jetzt ganz interessant ist in diesem Standard,
ist aber im Prinzip drin, dass so ein AirTag auch sagen kann,
dass es gerade bei seinem Besitzer ist und das soll also die Fehlmeldungen reduzieren.
Es ist erkennbar, ob das Gerät gerade sagt, mein Besitzer ist auch gerade bei
mir, alles gut oder mein Besitzer ist nicht gerade bei mir.
Und ich könnte, es ist erhöhte Stalking-Gefahr, ja.
Aber es ist natürlich, wenn du das Protokoll, also wenn du das Protokoll selber bestimmst,
ja, dann ist es halt relativ wenig Arbeit, etwas zu bauen oder etwas zu programmieren,
was eben die ganze Zeit sagt, keine Sorge, mein Besitzer ist bei mir,
ich stalk dich gerade nicht.
Eben am laufenden Band seine Location ändert.
Trotzdem, dass diese Stalking-Erkennung Schwächen hat, würde ich schon sagen,
also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht vergebens, so einen gemeinsamen technischen
Standard zu haben, weil ja.
Also selbstgebaute, bösartige Stalking-Geräte immer nochmal einen Schritt weiter sind, ja.
Das heißt, da muss jemand, der das machen möchte,
sich noch mehr mit auseinandersetzen, irgendwas eigenes bauen oder irgendwas
bösartiges kaufen und das heißt,
die untergraben diesem Missbrauch, so gut es eben geht, den Boden unter den Füßen weg,
in der hoffnung dass eben leute die stalken wollen mit so etwas dann am ende
doch wieder auf etwas zurückgreifen müssen das ja auffälliger ist nicht so einfach
nicht so elegant und dann vielleicht doch eher auffällt.
Ich glaube es ist vielleicht nochmal ganz wertvoll an dieser Stelle nochmal
kurz klar zu machen wie dieser eigentliche Zuordnungsmechanismus funktioniert, weil das haben wir jetzt,
so noch nicht genau gesagt und das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig auch jetzt.
Nochmal gerade bei dieser Bewertung dieser Anti-Stalking-Maßnahmen im Protokoll.
Und wenn der jetzt, und das wird dann quasi in dem eigenen iCloud Account abgelegt
und Apple weiß, aha, ein AirTag mit dieser ID gehört zu deinem Account.
So, und dann liegt das erstmal bei Apple.
Jetzt marschiert halt, marschiert man mit diesem AirTag durch die Gegend und
das sagt halt die ganze Zeit so, ich bin ein AirTag und ich bin hier.
Das ist sozusagen das, was die anderen Telefone dann sehen.
Die wissen aber nicht, wer das ist oder zu wem der gehört oder so und sammeln
das aber trotzdem ein und sagen,
naja kann ja vielleicht irgendjemand, vielleicht sucht das ja jemand,
ich pack mal hier meine aktuelle GPS-Koordinate dazu und mit so Schlüsseln,
die dann in dem was dieser AirTag aussendet, wird das dann eben verschlüsselt hingeschickt,
das heißt wenn das eigene Telefon ein anderes AirTag an Apple sendet,
Dann sendet man nicht seine eigene, also man sendet schon seine eigene Koordinate,
aber nicht die eigene Identität mit.
Und dann wird das dort abgelegt, diese Information, dass dieses Tag dort eben
zu diesem Zeitpunkt gesehen wurde.
Und wenn man jetzt halt selber nachschaut, wo hab ich denn hier mein Device
verloren, dann wird eben diese Information rausgegraben und man kann das auch
nur entschlüsseln, weil man es ursprünglich mal auch quasi bei diesem Anmeldevorgang gemacht hat.
So jetzt so ein Device, was sagt,
ja ich missachte alle Protokolle und ich sag einfach mal,
ich bin schon hier am richtigen Ort bei meinem Besitzer, alles überhaupt gar
keine Angst so, dieses Gerät muss ja dann auch erstmal zugelassen werden,
also wenn ich jetzt selber was baue.
Okay, sorry Tim, zugelassen werden. Na, von Apple.
Apple muss ja diese ID akzeptieren. Es muss ja dieses Gerät akzeptieren,
um es an diesem Netzwerk teilnehmen zu lassen. Wenn ich jetzt mir einfach was
baue, was irgendein Protokoll macht, kann ich das ja nicht automatisch dort anmelden.
Sobald es sich Protokoll von Conform verhält, schon.
Na, ich denke Apple würde derzeit erstmal nur AirTags von Apple selbst akzeptieren
und nicht ein anderes Gerät.
Nee, die akzeptieren... die kennen nicht alle IDs von allen Airtags.
Vielleicht nicht die ID, aber eben irgendeine kryptografische Identifizierung,
dass es sich dabei um das richtige Modell handelt.
Jein, das Protokoll ist jetzt nicht so schwer, dass sie da jetzt irgendwie noch
prüfen, ist das ein echtes Apple-Gerät, das machen sie bei allem anderen,
aber bei den AirTags gelingt das zumindest zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht.
Achso, okay, davon wäre ich aber rausgegangen, dass sie quasi die Konformität
dieses Gerätes herstellen können.
Nein.
Okay, können sie nicht.
Und das ist genau das, ich such das mal raus, du hast auch in die Shownotes,
der Angriff von Fabian, oder die Demonstration von Fabian, das geht auch nicht.
Also ich kann mir auch schwer vorstellen, dass das...
Na ich dachte, dass sie da irgendeinen Schlüssel in diesem AirTag drin haben,
der einfach von Apple gesigned ist und wenn das nicht da ist,
dann wird das Ding nicht hinzugefügt.
Nee. Und wenn, nee, nee, das ist, ich glaube die würfeln sogar ihren Schlüssel
einfach, wenn sie mal Strom verloren haben, lang genug verloren haben, einfach wieder neu.
Okay, das wundert mich aber jetzt sehr.
Ja, das wundert dich vielleicht ist aber seit Juli, 15.
Juli 21, oh nee, da gab's hier der letzte, also seit über zwei Jahren ist das
bekannt, dass das so ist.
Und deswegen gibt es halt auch dieses Open Haystack, also das ist nicht nennenswert
problematisch, das etwas zu bauen, wo du halt einfach mehrere registrierst.
Das ist nicht so schwierig, wie du denkst.
Okay.
Also die Keys sind wahrscheinlich einfach zu kurz als das Apple oder zu lang
als das Apple jetzt sagen könnte, nee, das ist ein AirTag, das haben wir in
den Handel gebracht und das nicht.
Ich denke, das Problem, was jetzt gelöst wird, ist, dass die Systeme,
die es gibt, sich darauf einigen, wenigstens gemeinsamen Schutz zu bieten.
Die Situation war ja vorher so, wenn du als Stalker jetzt irgendwie hingehst
und du weißt, die Zielperson hat ein iPhone, dann nimmst du natürlich nicht
ein AirTag, weil das iPhone erkennt das AirTag.
Wenn du weißt, die hat ein Android, dann nimmst du nicht so einen Android-Tracker,
sondern nimmst einen Apple-Tracker, weil das Android-Gerät nicht das Apple-Ding erkennt.
Das heißt, jeder Hersteller hat nur die Warnungen für sein eigenes Ökosystem
ausgegeben, was es natürlich den Angreifern sehr einfach machte,
einfach ein anderes Gerät zu nehmen.
Ja, und wenn du jetzt, also wenn die Szene jetzt ist, du schnappst eine Person,
die du irgendwie in der Bar oder in der Disco siehst, die hat ja eh 85 Mal auf
ihr Handy geguckt in der Zeit, wo sie da ist. Da weißt du, ob die ein iPhone
oder ein Android hat und könntest eben entsprechendes Gerät wählen.
Das geht jetzt nicht mehr oder das wird bald nicht mehr gehen,
weil dir eben der Tracking-Schutz vereinheitlicht wird über die Herstellenden. Das ist schon mal gut.
Gleichzeitig ist auch dieser Tracking-Schutz nicht perfekt und das scheint für
mich nicht wirklich lösbar zu sein, den auch wirklich perfekt zu machen.
Also es ist ein richtiger Schritt, denke ich. Er wird das Problem weiter einengen in seiner Größe.
Er wird sich vollständig eliminieren.
Und ja, ich würde sagen so, dass man diese Gefahr nicht vollständig bannen kann,
aber dass man sie natürlich nach allen technischen Möglichkeiten einschränken sollte.
Und das scheint mir jetzt hier langsam der Fall zu sein. Dass es immer wieder
Ränder gibt, wie man die Dinge umgehen kann mit irgendwelchen selbst ausgebauten Geräten und so weiter.
Ja, das wird so bleiben, aber dann sind wir irgendwann auch,
und das ist mein Punkt, da wo wir schon immer oder wo wir jetzt schon seit vielen
Jahren waren, seit man GPS-Tracker kaufen kann.
Dass man mit selbstgebauten Geräten und hohem technischen Aufwand jemanden tracken
kann, ist halt seit 20 Jahren der Fall.
Was neu war ist dass man sich dafür ein winzig kleinen chip kaufen kann für
35 euro und dass jeder idiot hinbekommt und den idioten machen sie es jetzt
wieder schwieriger ich denke so lässt man lässt sich das zusammenfassen und
eben die öko ökosysteme arbeiten jetzt zusammen statt statt in ihren eigenen zoos.
Ist ja auch überhaupt interessant, was das nochmal auch für so eine Plattform
Power auch nochmal gezeigt hat, dieses Feature.
Ich meine so im Bereich von Apps und so weiter sind wir das ja schon gewohnt,
beziehungsweise ist das Problem auch schon verstanden.
Aber dass eben diese pure Präsenz der Geräte und die damit verbundene Networking
Fähigkeit also sozusagen nochmal so ein Verbundnetz aller iPhones,
die zusammenarbeiten ohne direkt was miteinander zu tun zu haben,
dass das auch nochmal so eine Kraft hat, das ist ja auch nochmal ein ganz interessantes
Phänomen an sich und es ist ja wirklich bemerkenswert wie weit das reicht und
wie gut man Sachen damit trecken kann.
Ja, in Städten ist es natürlich einfacher als auf dem Land, ganz klar.
Aber auch da funktioniert das ganz gut.
Ja, also es hat, ich muss tatsächlich sagen, die AirTags verwende ich verhältnismäßig selten.
Was ich schon durchaus öfter mache, ist irgendwie, okay, wo ist das Laptop,
wo sind die Airpods, solche Dinge, wo sind die Geräte?
Also bei den, die Geräte sind halt, ja, also da passiert das schon gerne mal,
ne, wo hast du jetzt den Airport oder so.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall auch. Also ich hab grad mal gezählt, ich hab so elf Airtags derzeit im Einsatz.
Das ist ein Leben in Angst, Tim.
Wieso in Angst?
Elf Geräte, was hast du denn jetzt alles getaggt? Hast du irgendwie eine Schafsherde?
Also Schlüsselbunde, da mehr als eins.
Okay auch falsch ich hab nur eins.
Und dann so mein default Reisekoffer und Reiserucksäcke und Taschen wo ich so
Wertsachen drin habe so Umhänge, Beuteltaschen sowas.
Also vor allem so meine default Koffertaschen, die ich so in der Regel in der
Reise dabei habe und die ich auch schon mal im Zug hab liegen lassen und die,
wenn sie mir wirklich abhanden kommen würden, dann auch ein echtes Problem darstellen würden.
Das ist eigentlich so das Primäre.
Und dann halt so Fahrzeuge irgendwie, also ich glaub's ja gar nicht,
wie leicht man vergisst, wo man sein Auto abgestellt hat.
Ach du hast ihn echt im Auto liegen, ja? Aber piept der da nicht irgendwann?
Ja der piept dann ein bisschen rum irgendwie, aber stört dann eigentlich auch
nicht groß, hörst ja auch kaum.
So ein großer Schutz ist das.
Und müsste eigentlich auch weggehen, sobald du da wieder einsteigst, ne?
Jaja das schon, wenn jetzt jemand anders mit dem fährt,
also was leider ja nicht geht ist, irgendwas ist mit deinem Auto töst,
liegt jetzt nicht an einer Stelle wo es dich die ganze Zeit stört und es piept
ja auch nicht ewig weiter,
aber es ist schon sehr praktisch und reassuring in gewisser Hinsicht auch,
so zu wissen so das Fahrrad steht immer noch am gleichen Ort,
So oder zumindest das AirTag ist immer noch im gleichen Ort.
Also vielleicht ist es nicht, also ein Leben ohne AirTag ist möglich,
aber manchmal finde ich es dann doch sehr praktisch und beruhigend.
Das würde ich sagen ist so der Hauptvektor dabei. Naja.
Ja, aber okay, also hier eine, ja man könnte sagen, eine gute Nachricht,
dass der Missbrauch eingedämmt wird.
Joa, dann war eigentlich schon am Ende der Sendung,
bevor es wieder in den Kommentaren kommt, gleich nochmal,
ich hatte mich vorhin im Namen geirrt,
ich hatte Dominik Raab gesagt, das war nicht der Name den ich erinnert hätte,
haben sollte, Sondern Matt Hancock war einer von denen, die von Led by Donkeys
da sozusagen mit dieser Fake Firma aus Südkorea dazu gebracht wurden solche
Tagessätze aufzurufen.
Weißt du wer Matt Hancock ist? Nee.
Matt Hancock war Gesundheitsminister während der Covid-19 Pandemie.
Ist auch jetzt nicht besonders gut in Erinnerung geblieben mit seinem Handling.
Und ist dann Juni 21 zurückgetreten, weil
er irgendwie eine ranghohe Mitarbeiterin sexuell bedrängt hat und ja später
ist er dann bei in der englischen Version des Dschungelcamps irgendwie untergekommen,
Hat auch einen dritten Platz gemacht, aber ist aus der Fraktion von Tories rausgeflogen,
deswegen, das ging dann nicht.
Also so tausende Leute sterben lassen und so weiter, das geht alles.
Aber Dschungelcamp, das ist dann für die Tories, für die Elite dann doch zu viel.
First things first, sag ich nur. Das Leben muss Prioritäten haben.
Ja, dann haben wir es, oder?
Ja, Leute, bis nächste Woche.
Bis nächste Woche. Tschau tschau!